[Music]
okay everybody
hi steve hey how you doing i'm really
excited to talk to you guys um
as you guys can see i'm talking to jimmy
gonzalez aka omar
and dennis quaid aka captain wade and
their new film is out today blue miracle
how you guys doing today
great pretty good so my first question
is for dennis dennis was there any
challenges to filming on a boat like did
you get seasick at all during this film
no because we shot most of it in a tank
a big huge tank that was right on the
beach in the dominican republic
and they could make waves in this thing
any
thing you want i mean they could make
you seasick really easily
but you know we were doing a movie with
kids and they only get to shoot like six
hours a day and it
takes like two hours to get out to see
so uh it would have been uh
yeah we'd still be shooting the movie if
we'd gone that way
yeah no i i totally get that now
jimmy how do you approach playing a
character that's based off someone in
real life is there a different
uh approach as an actor to doing a role
like that yeah um
i think that it for for papa omar what i
really
sunk into was his relationship with the
kids his relationship with his
with his wife uh and and the
relationship that he ends up having with
captain
wade and it just and plus you know
the real omar's life is very similar to
mine and in many ways and so i
i had a lot of advantages coming into it
yeah no and and you absolutely crush it
there and
it's so great because the other side of
the coin is no problem is
dennis playing captain wade now with
captain wade dennis how much of dennis
did you find
in captain wade oh you're always
i mean as an actor you're always playing
yourself or whatever
but that you know captain wade had won
this
tournament actually twice the first time
straight up the second time he cheated a
bit and uh
you know so he comes into this uh kind
of a
rather jaded person really who very ego
driven and uh
uh puts importance on all the wrong
things
if you ask me and that was what was
great about you the arc of the character
with these these orphans that were
foisted upon him
and he reluctantly took on in order to
be in the tournament then
it was a very turned out to be a very
humbling experience for him
and a reminder he was like a person
looking for redemption and he didn't
even know it
yeah no and that really sums it up
perfectly and it's so exciting to see
these two
great characters you guys play so before
i let you guys go
in this movie that i loved for people
who haven't seen it this weekend the
scroll through netflix this question is
for both of you first jimmy if you can
answer why blue miracle why should
someone give this a shot
well first and foremost i mean casa oh
god is a story that that
it needs to be told and be heard you
know i mean it's it's full of
inspiration
uh it's it's it's full of literally a
miracle which happened every day
i think and considering what we just
went through
i don't think we can have enough of
these kinds of stories out there
love it dennis why should we watch this
because it's entertaining
but that i think that's why hell yeah
you heard the first thing to go to see a
movie for i'm gonna i'll go to a
classroom for
if i would have learned something you
know with a big big message but you get
that anyway you know with the telling of
the story
it just makes you feel really good and
uh
it's it's just a great movie and like he
said you know
inspirational stories that after the
bummer year that we had over the last
year it's
it's uh time to see some really positive
things
yeah yep and it's exactly that movie
everyone you heard it from them
themselves
thank you so much guys for joining me
today everybody check out blue miracle
it's out on netflix today
watch with the family it'll make you
guys feel great you'll cry laugh
inspired
everything it's so much fun thank you
for joining me i hope to talk to you
guys
thank you you bet see you later have a
good one